[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
someone says in the chat I need an extra
five minutes
you blame me
[Music]
now what are you gonna do
we're a few minutes late that's okay
it's a holiday we're here
we're loud we're proud and we want to
say thank you to all the veterans out
there especially the ones who gave up
their lives so we have freedom we have
the freedom
in this country to be who we want to be
love who we want to love
the pursuit of happiness life and
Liberty that's what it's all about
that's what the pro-democracy Coalition
is all about so not only the veterans
who lost their lives in action to make
that impossibility but also all the
veterans in the audience and all the
family members of the audience who have
served in the armed forces to protect
our Liberty and our freedom
the Cheeto dust q and Honor doesn't like
certain Americans though he doesn't like
people who like Liberty
you know even if they were veterans he
didn't like them he didn't like them and
really the the guy running against him
meatball
he wants to destroy destroy liberalism
and wokeism what the f okay all right I
I gotta say Ron man dude
I'm not one to consult Republican
campaigns but man you went on Fox news
this morning I'm gonna show you guys
this clip he won a Fox news this morning
and gave
his
closing argument this morning
like what the [__] are you kidding me
his closing argument is
I can beat Joe Biden in the general
election and I'm going to destroy his
word not mine
leftism and wokeism in this country does
he have any idea how unpopular his
little war on wookism actually is his
war on Disney did you see did you see
the numbers
of The Little Mermaid I went and seen
The Little Mermaid on Friday
evening we went to see Little Mermaid
now I I'm not gonna ruin the movie for
you I I the live action movies of Disney
Live Action it kind of I don't know when
we call like this movie live action I
mean there is live action parts of it
but it really does kind of discount all
the work that the animators did
I mean there's a lot of Animation in
this thing
a lot
um especially with the under the sea
music part of the movie
but let me let me tell you something you
[__] anti-wokers or you you Maga you
domestic terrorist is what you are
because you're threatening violence
against stores like Target which is
causing them to
protect their employees and
and not have you [__] domestic
terrorists
trying to terrorize their employees and
their customers
let me tell you something about the war
on wokism and your little war on the
lgbtq community it's not working
it's not and it's not gonna work
really honestly you should get a
different stick
I mean
your war on wokism which is black people
and your war on the leftism the lgbtq
community
is almost almost
is bad at rallying a huge wave of people
to vote against you as the Roe v Wade
where you're you're stripping away a
woman's right to Health Care
that by the way on Memorial Day I just
want to mention a Memorial Day veterans
fought women
veterans fought for the right so that
they could have health care in this
country and you're Banning it and
stripping away from them you're Banning
the right for people who love each other
be who they are dress how they want to
dress you people aren't for Freedom
Ronda Santa's saying he's gonna destroy
leftism really
your youth you believe that your best
effort to be president United States is
to eradicate an idea
people's belief people's political
stance really that's where you're going
with it [__] Hitler come on man these
people are [__] Nazis I've told you
that time and time and time again I'm
gonna keep yelling and screaming because
they are he's a [__] Nazi and the
only reason why he's making these
arguments now which sound like closing
arguments
I'm going to show you the clip and you
[__] decide but this sounds like a
closing argument to me this does not
sound like an opening argument he's not
he's not drawing differences between him
and Trump in the primary and the reason
why is because he can't attack Trump
he's too much of a [__] [__] Ron
DeSantis that is
that little [__] can't attack Trump
because he's terrified he's terrified
he's a weak little [__] coward why do
you think at gitmo when they were
torturing detainees he was laughing
because he's a coward
he's got coward written all over his
face every time he speaks
and to say that you're going to destroy
an idea listen I am not a fan of fascism
you all know that you know I'm not a fan
of fascism at all not even just a little
hint of ashism it kind of pisses me off
kinda
here's the thing though I understand and
I told you this we cannot get rid of
ideas that's the one problem with these
[__] boneheads
releasing this [__] into the universe is
we can't we can't undo those ideas
you can't undo them you can only do
things in our democracy and democracies
around the world
to make sure that they crawl back
underneath their [__] rocks and they
go into hiding
and they hide away because they're not
popular
and no one wants to have them as a
member of society we have to ask we have
to ostracize them we have to make sure
that they are the pariahs
in society
they can have the right I mean you can
have your bigoted [__] views your
race is big and abused you can't act on
them those are [__] hate crimes but
you can have your bigoted [__] views
you can believe all kinds of bigoted ass
[__] that's your freedom in this country
veterans fought for you to be a dumb
[__] they really did they fought for you
to have the freedom be a dumb
[__] and believe Antiquated
stupid ideas
really dumb [__] that you got the right
that's your [__] right to be stupid
fine ignorant whatever you want to call
it that's your right you don't get to
act on it again those are hate crimes I
believe what some of these [__]
chuckleheads are doing going inside
Target and destroying Pride displays
because they hate the lgbtq community
that's a hate crime it's a crime and
it's done out of hate it's a hate crime
got it you got it you domestic [__]
terrorist do you understand
anyways
Rhonda Santos's goal is to destroy
leftism I mean you know they're saying
the quiet part out loud again they want
you to not be able to think a certain
way that's why they want to ban certain
books that's why they want to ban
certain curriculum because all these
facts all the facts and all the reality
of of what our society is today all the
things we know leads to I don't know
people wanting rights freedoms Liberty
and it just it smells like liberalism is
what it smells like because that's what
liberalism is
it's Freedom it's Choice it's
opportunity now we can all disagree in
the pro-democracy Coalition of what
extent of liberalism adopts from
communist
Marxist socialists are just like the
left in general right they want to paint
that up that's what Cheeto does q and
honor that's what that's what Grandpa
poopy pants that's how he's hating on
[__] veterans this today is that if
you're a Democrat and you're a [__]
veteran you're a piece of [__] and we
need to get rid of you he hates veterans
Trump hates veterans he hates what
veterans have done for our country which
is give us the liberty to govern
ourselves
because we are the government we we are
the Republic it is US folks and that's
what really pisses them off more than
anything is that we get to tell them
what the [__] to do
uh just like this morning uh this debt
ceiling thing
um as I predicted Jill Biden
had this in his pocket the whole time
listen uh Joe Biden is probably not
going to go down as the best the best
most intelligent greatest president of
all time but in our modern history I
don't see in the next 20 30 years and I
don't see 20 30 40 years behind us a
more effective president than Joe Biden
one of the reasons why is one of the
things that they knock him the most for
which is INS it it kind of baffles me
when something like this happens Joe
Biden completely played Kevin McCarthy
like a [__] fiddle here
um brilliantly by the way brilliantly
now a lot of people are upset about the
snap
um age moving it's really that's about
the only goddamn thing Joe Biden gave up
was the snap age for a work requirement
you got to remember this it's work
requirement and not only did they did
they they just moved a work requirement
from 49 to 54. they they have a ton of
exemptions those exemptions include
veterans and homeless people so you can
receive snap you can get food you can
you can receive assistance and in most
cases it seems like that this that this
moving from 49 to 54 for the work
requirement isn't even going to have an
effect
on the program not only that Joe Biden
got debts excuse me he got the debt
ceiling they didn't negotiate on that at
all
but he got student debt relief
so these Republicans are gonna vote
in this budget to give student debt
relief folks
you don't think that's huge for the
economy just wait just [__] wait and
Kevin McCarthy took this deal and the
reason why Kevin McCarthy took this deal
is because Joe Biden saved his ass until
the election
there's gonna be no budget fight there's
gonna be no more debt ceiling Kevin
McCarthy can pretend to be as flashy as
he wants from now until the election and
not get anything done they've got a
budget debt ceilings raised we're going
to probably
avoid any kind of economic crisis from
now until the time that Joe Biden's
re-elected and you the pro-democracy
Coalition fire Kevin McCarthy and fire
the Republicans from the House of
Representatives give more democratic
votes in the United States Senate make
sure Governors are Democrats make sure
these state legislators aren't aren't
super majority Republicans that's what
we're going to do that's what we need to
do that is the the backing of this fight
and that should be the excitement behind
this deal
is that this lays the groundwork for the
foundation for Democrats and the
pro-democracy coalition to absolutely
[__] Stamp Out fascism in our
governments everywhere all the way down
to the [__] dog catcher United States
Senate the House of Representatives our
state Executive offices our state
legislators
our city councils our school boards all
the way down to the ones that capture
stray animals out in the streets
and it's it's up to us it's up to us
because these [__] boneheads out
there these manga these moglodytes
they're fighting over who was worse on
covid
in March April May of 2 2020
they're arguing about they're arguing
about if the January 6 insurrectionist
the violent terrorists who tried to
overthrow our government should be
pardoned
and they're also arguing whether or not
whether or not
that Donald Trump should be crowned king
of all time
what more perfect thing can we have than
infighting from them while we organize
why we use our strategic outrage why we
find candidates in these state and local
races
for the long term not for the short term
for the long term
what better ground work than what Joe
Biden has laid at the pro-democracies
coalition's feat
even Jay Palace behind this she's gonna
vote for this [__] thing the
Democrats are going to have a little bit
of outrage because they want their they
want their Democratic Socialist base
on that on the far left to know that oh
well we're a little upset about this
I mean I gotta have a little bit right
uh you know I'm talking about come on
there's a few of you in here uh who
probably hate this deal who absolutely
love love Bernie Sanders and AOC which
is fine that's that's fine you're in
part of the pro-democracy Coalition and
you have a right to you know air your
grievances to the couple dozen people
who are going to listen
most people most people in this country
see this as a good deal for Americans
that's why Joe Biden is going to see it
be seen as one of the most effective
presidents of our modern time
he may not be the best he may not be the
brightest the most the the most the
greatest at speeches
but he's [__] effective you want to
know why do you want to know why Joe
Biden's so [__] effective if you
think back on all the prisons that we've
had in modern history what president in
modern history can you think of that has
been more [__] more [__] involved
than have more experience in the federal
government and how legislation and how
the executive branch works the Joe Biden
find me one
find me find me an executive the last
guy you had no [__] clue he couldn't
even hardly pretend to be president
the guy the guy before that Barack Obama
super smart super intelligent great
order right
he could really he could really [__]
use a microphone
brilliant sharp is a [__] Tech knew
exactly what he was saying
constitutional a constitutional lawyer
right
thing about this
he was only in the federal government
for a couple years as his United States
Senator before he became president what
about the guy before that George W bush
W he was a governor
that guy before that Clinton he was a
[__] governor
see you point out to me you point out to
me someone that's going to be known is
more effective and it's likely it's
likely that our next president in the
United States in 2028
in 2028 could be another Governor a
Democratic governor it seems poised that
there's going to be several Governors
Whitmer hulkel possible Newsom
several Democratic Governors that will
run
to be president
so it is unlikely that we will have an
hour in our next 20 years
of someone who has more experience in
the federal government than Joe Biden
has
and it shows
it shows not only does it show in this
negotiation but it shows
in his demeanor of this negotiation when
asked when asked why didn't you do this
scenery is like why the [__] would I do
that I wouldn't have done any good
anyways
there's no way he could have brought
Kevin McCarthy to the table no way and
got this deal two months ago
Joe Biden knew exactly what he was doing
now my view of it is I I wish which this
is a wish this is a wish list uh item
it's not gonna happen
and I've told you this before I think
they should 14th that [__] the
debt ceiling is unconstitutional it's a
stupid fight we have it's ridiculous for
the American people to sit chewing their
nails who are paying attention to it
waiting for the economy to crash using
fear tactics and threats from
Republicans to hold our [__] budget
in the top line
hostage
while they [__] work out why they're
gonna [__] raise the debt ceiling
[__] you that's unconstitutional 14th
that thing that's what I feel that
should be done now Joe Biden delivered
us the next best best thing which is a a
complete clean slate
and a great Foundation to take back our
democracy not just at the federal level
but all the way down to the state level
folks is what he did
imagine imagine going into
2024 into a general election and there's
going to be a republican who either
voted for this to raise and and the debt
ceiling and give students student debt
relief I I know I'm harping on this but
this is one just one pinprick of this
Vote or imagine them going into debate
with the Democratic candidate and and
not voting
to raise the debt ceiling and to give
American student debt relief imagine
just imagine the popularity of them
we can politicize the [__] out of this J
this is a gift that Joe Biden has given
us this is a gift that Kevin McCarthy
felt asked backwards into he doesn't
just know it yet and the only reason why
he did this Kevin McCarthy because
because he wanted to save his job
it's the same reason why Kevin McCarthy
made all the concessions to the [__]
manga lunatics it's the reason why Jim
Jordan and Jim Comer are chairman of
[__] committees
because he caved because he wants his
power he wants his job that's what he
wants that's what he desires it's the
only thing that Kevin McCarthy wants to
do is say I became speaker and I held it
from one election to the next
I wasn't ousted and Joe Biden delivered
that for Kevin McCarthy and really
honestly who would Joe Biden want better
than Kevin McCarthy to be speaker at
this point of these [__] nincompoops
they're not going to get anything done
and they're definitely going to step on
rakes the entire way
so good good let them have Kevin
McCarthy let them have their [__]
nincompoot speaker
and let the moglodytes continue to to
talk about culture wars
they're they're losing they're [__]
losing because the American people
aren't gonna buy this [__] they think
they are they think they they got the
American people's hearts here they don't
they don't you really think that
majority of Americans walk into a Target
and see a a display with Rainbow clothes
and they lose their [__] minds no
it's five ten people on tick tock
okay and they work up a bunch of [__]
terrorists to to threaten violence
give me a [__] break most Americans
are not [__] terrified of rainbows
they're just not and they're definitely
not [__] terrified if someone else
they don't know loves whoever they want
to love they don't give a [__]
because they don't want you in their
[__] bedroom they don't want you and
other people's [__] bedrooms okay
just leave it the [__] alone
enough with your nonsense
and and the more they yell and scream
about about like Bud Light and Target
and Walmart and Kohl's and rainbows
it's only going to get worse for them
it's only going to get worse and really
honestly I think this is all a
distraction from Roe v Wade
and how they banned Women's Healthcare
all around all around the country they
knew row row
striking down Row in 2022 was a horrible
mistake
it it totally threw a wet blanket all
over their Red Wave
and the reason why is because the people
said whoa whoa whoa whoa wait a second I
thought Republicans were for Freedom
that's not Freedom that's anti-freedom
because they're the party of no Freedom
they're the party of white Christian
nationalists they're the party of real
America First Nazis that's who they are
that's their personality
and they're going to drive that home and
we must politicize it the other thing we
have to do do is the pro-democracy
Coalition is to engage and drive those
wedges between them because I'm telling
you there's sentiment out there that
this culture war and this this war
against lgbtq Community is going to have
huge backlash next year you can hear it
you can hear the ground look beneath
them and the one reason why is you can
see this in the fight between Trump and
DeSantis
that DeSantis has taken his war on the
lgbtq community the wokism black people
and leftists
he's taken it too far with things like
Disney and and going full-on fashion in
Florida
and instituting fascist policies
and attacking private business as much
as you may disagree with them
well what do you what do you think what
do you think going against Target but
lidar
yeah you may disagree with him so what
who gives a [__] you're not big enough
to destroy them go go look go look at
Anheuser-Busch stock go look at Target
and Disney stock go look at them go take
a peek go take a peek and you'll see
how Americans actually feel and what I
mean by Americans is I mean the market
you stupid [__] what do you think
capitalism is capitalism is a form of
voting you vote with money
the more money the more votes yes it's
not fair
it's not a system of equity or equality
in the economy
but it is a system of democracy it is a
system of voting
and you stupid bastards are losing
you're losing your culture War and the
reason why is because you're actually
you're actually making corporations and
capitalism your enemy here that's what
they're doing
and they're going to continue to do it
and the reason why is because they know
they [__] up when they when they
decided that the war on women was the
war that they wanted to fight in 2022
and they saw what women and allies with
Women's Health Care
was was going to do to them no no [__]
you're not taking away women's health
care you're not going to take you're not
going to take my daughters my mothers my
wives my sisters my friends Health Care
away from them and when the country
stood up and said hell to the no even in
Kansas and Idaho Kentucky Michigan said
no on referendums you are not going to
[__] with Women's Health Care
not gonna happen
they realized they needed a pivot and
all of a sudden all of a sudden they
found out about transgender people do
you notice that do you know what I said
everyone's pointing out that that Tesla
SpaceX which are elon's companies he's
the CEO he's the head he's the head
McKees moose he's a head cheese over
there
they've been celebrating pride month for
[__] years
get out of here this [__] isn't new
you boneheads had to Pivot from one
issue to the next and we shouldn't
forget either one of them folks we have
to make them pay politically for both
decisions here because they have no real
policy that's why Rhonda santis on Fox
news this morning sounds like a closing
argument
when he could attack Trump on his
[__] Memorial Day
post on fraud social attacking veterans
attacking veterans folks
so now's the time that we engage in our
democracy Now's the Time on Memorial Day
we have these conversations with our
neighbors our friends our family our
colleagues
Now's the Time
Now's the Time to start speaking out
and start raising awareness of what
these boneheads are actually trying to
do to our country and what their plan is
for our country
as Joe Biden sets up one of the best
best foundations of a democratic
pro-democracy coalition to run and win
in all corners of this country I'm
telling you I know you don't think it I
know you you know Tony it's not that
great [__] it ain't
[__] it ain't I'm telling you I I'm
telling you Joe Biden has more
experience in the federal government and
he plays these things way better than
anyone else I've ever seen
I've been following politics for a long
time long time
and Joe Biden is President he is one of
the most effective right and you may not
like his policies you may not like how
far he goes or he doesn't go far enough
or he goes too far maybe he's slow maybe
he's his age bothers you maybe how he
speaks bothers you
well let me tell you something
guys effective
and it's gonna show in history
you doubt me 20 30 years from now
a lot of people are going to give a lot
of credit for Obama's administration to
Joe Biden because of how effective of a
president he actually is I'm serious
dead serious may it may not be a fair
assessment but it's going to happen
he is a very very very effective
president because he knows the
government of the United States and he
knows how to get it to deliver for the
American people
he just does there's a gist [__]
simple facts and if you don't like him
fine whatever whatever he if you don't
like those facts well then that's on you
that's a you problem it's not a Joe
Biden problem
but today on Memorial Day know the
contrast know the contrast to what the
president of the United States Joe Biden
is actually doing for the American
people
to the contrast of what his opponent
Donald Trump the Cheeto does queuing on
her Grandpa poopy pants
and what his message is today know the
contrast on this Memorial Day as we
remember those who have fallen don't go
anywhere we're going to be right back
full two hours today on this holiday
right back
right after this
[Music]
what the [__] is wrong with you people
people it's a rhetorical question at
best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment where
[Music]
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
foreign
[Music]
holiday weekend I'm I'm glad all of you
are here holy moly what a great turnout
for a holiday on a Monday people were
asking me if we were gonna do this
and I said I think on Friday Thursday
and Friday I think we're gonna we're
gonna do this
um we're gonna we're gonna go through
Memorial Day we did Memorial Day we did
Labor Day last year I would say that
we're probably gonna we're probably
gonna take off
um for the Fourth of July is probably
what will the next holiday that will
have where we won't have a show at a
regular time and then you know we'll
probably go all the way to Thanksgiving
Christmas and New Year's for those other
holidays now next week Monday June 5th
and June 6th so Monday and Tuesday I
will not be here Gabe Sanchez will
um he's gonna take over the reins here
he's going to run the show
um and so be prepared so next Monday or
Tuesday you got to show up you gotta
show Gabe's support and give him give
him a lot of give him a lot of support
here he's gonna run the show next Monday
and Tuesday and of course uh Tuesday
Texas Paul will be with him and then
Monday maybe we'll get him a guest
co-host or some guest or something like
that we'll figure that out this week
we'll figure that out
we'll figure that out this week
[Music]
so that's kind of our our view on
holidays
I really don't um
I really don't view that the holidays
would stop me from doing a show I mean
other than maybe the major ones again
like July 4th uh Thanksgiving Christmas
New Year's I figure you're spending time
with your family on those holidays I
probably should too but I had a great
weekend I hope you guys have had a good
Memorial Day weekend I'm not done now
we're gonna go do some things this
afternoon when the show is over so
well we're not done celebrating Memorial
day but we we did some grilling we had
some fun we we played some music maybe
added maybe had a few to drink possibly
possibly could have done some
recreational marijuana I don't know it's
possible it's a possible thing that we
did this weekend I know it was a great
Memorial Day weekend
I'm happy that uh got some time to spend
with friends and family and I hope I
hope you did too I hope you did too uh
so again again we'll probably we
probably won't take another vacation
from from the show until the 4th of July
whenever that is I don't even know is it
over the weekend this year or is it like
in the middle of the [__] week
but more likely will take two or three
show days
um for the Fourth of July
um so that'll be our next holiday that
we won't have shows
uh and then again it won't be until
later in the year every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central for two full hours you know you
can count on the Tony Michaels podcast
being here I've done a few times the
show without my voice one in particular
it was really bad that was last year and
then I think um I think this year I I
was I was hoarse it's allergies that
does it to me
sometimes I lose my voice because of my
allergy attacks
um I only get one or two a year
most the time so it's a Tuesday they're
saying so July 4th is a Tuesday so my
guess is we will probably if it is on a
Tuesday we'll probably take Monday
Tuesday Wednesday so I have like a five
day weekend
so I'm like Thursday Friday that we'll
have for the show that week so we'll get
to do bonehead that's always good we
missed a few boneheads because of how
well Thanksgiving always falls on the
Friday so we always lose bonehead that
week but we we lost a bonehead during
Christmas because of how Christmas fell
or it wasn't New Year's I don't remember
but then we'll add bonehead that week at
least we're bonehead of the week that
week it's gonna be good so that'll be
good
everyone's rooting for Gabe uh next week
yeah he'll do great he'll do great I'm
gonna show him how to do the uh give him
the rundown on the intro he already
knows how to do the controls so he'll
he'll be able to figure that but I'm
gonna give him the steps so it looks
almost the same and then he asked he has
to he's gonna have to stay on the mic
for like 30 minutes for that a block
you think he can do it I think he can do
it I think he's gonna have no trouble
um doing it you know if I was him if I'm
just saying if I was Gabe Sanchez I just
play a few what was that I don't get you
that'll get you at least you know 20
minutes maybe play three of them 25
minutes maybe you get through uh some
what was that he could explain it to you
I don't know I I mean again there's a
lot of options I think we could get some
good guests
um that Gabe can hang out with maybe we
have a guest co-host
um next week on on Monday Texas Paul
will be here on Tuesday with him and I
might pop in now I might make an
appearance
um but I'm not going to be running the
show the day I need a little bit of a
break I'm gonna go hang out and do some
things so and I appreciate that you guys
uh that you guys are willing to to hang
with us as we do some of that and maybe
I'll do more um guest co-hosting where
Gabe will do some co-hosting or we'll
have a guest host on that um maybe we'll
do that I don't know what do you guys
think should we do some guest host or
some guest co-hosts like Gabe hosting
that would give me a little a few days
uh here and there
um but again I I this is really more
than anything this as much as this is
for you guys this is this is my kind of
therapy right this is my happy place
this is where I come to uh to let loose
get my um get my rage up give you guys
some cathartic release
um and and you know when we talk about
politics
um it's it's it's more it's more than
just it's more than just strategic
outrage I mean we're we're laying
groundwork here at this show
um that is going to continue for the
next two or three decades
and I know what it some people go hahaha
yeah right yeah right okay well you just
[__] hide and watch you just [__]
hide and watch
I'm I've seen exactly how the right wing
does it I know how talk radio did it
I've watched it looked at it and I've
thought about it and we're gonna do it
here this is the way it's gonna be this
is the way we're gonna do it it's
working
and what I mean by that is most of our
viewers watch from the very first minute
to the very last minute of this show
they watched the whole [__] and
a lot of them are watching on their
goddamn TVs right now how many of you
out there in the chat are right now
watching this on a well you can't chat
see that's the thing
is if they're on a TV they can't chat I
don't think can you maybe you can I
don't know I don't think the YouTube app
there's a YouTube app let you chat
if you got it on the the the the the TV
I I don't know I don't know maybe it
does
um again everyone's asking about the
debt ceiling and that sort of thing look
uh yes yep yes yes
um on my TV yeah okay all right yeah see
they're on their TV
so no chat from TV hey you can't chat on
the TV
so you had to come to the [__] the
broadcast to say that
oh man
well I I am I am so happy
um that you guys enjoy this show and not
only that you enjoy this show that
eventually we'll have an audience
um here that not only loves this show
but loves to to hate this show
um so someone's saying Richard Ojeda
should be a host you know I actually I
was talking to him the other day we were
we were talking about maybe coming on
each other's show what do you guys think
nah major or Jetta Blue Dot Dusty said
Richard Ojeda should be the should be a
guest host I wouldn't I wouldn't be
opposed to
to Major making appearance as a guest
host I don't know
I don't know
I kind of I kind of wanted uh someone
prettier than me Gaber
the major though you know what I mean uh
Dr Rachel bittickoffer hey there you go
that's a good one oh man
oh man that could be pretty good right
right see that I I would say Hal Sparks
but it he runs like the same the same
time
as me so I don't know
I don't know if um
I don't know if he'd be able to do that
um and make that work but we have a ton
of sparklers always in the chat so uh
Sparkles are always welcome here at the
Tony Michaels podcast we um we love
having you here and I know mine and
Hal's times intersex sometimes like they
overlap he does different shows at
different times and sometimes we kind of
um bang up against each other and people
have said before we need to change our
times but that that's just not how it's
gonna work and then we're not competing
like I'm not like competing with hell
and he's not competing with me or trying
to we're just we're just doing it at the
time that we think is best for us
so
yeah
some people are saying they're sparklers
they like to watch they like to watch
both and welcome to all the sparklers
I'm glad to have them uh no show Tuesday
Thursday am for Hal so he's not running
shows this week
I don't know it's hard for me to keep up
with everybody and I don't watch oh yeah
Mighty Librarians is Jess Piper that she
could be a great
a great guest co-host or guest host that
would be a good option you guys really
like just by I like Jess but she's she's
brilliant and just just not only is
brilliant but she's got she's got this
uh this vision of what these state
legislators can can do and how how how
to change and reshape
um state governments and so that that
Republicans don't have
the super majorities where you actually
run you run a Democrat
um in these in these places so
um and she's she's brilliant now maybe
we should get Jess on this week uh for
some updates uh if she has any
I'm sure there'll be something come up
this week that will make me
want to say Jess come on the show so
maybe we can maybe we can get Jess on
the in the show uh lee McGowan politics
girl yeah she'd be a great ghost too
she'd be a great
great co-host guest host
sure sure why not I'm open to all kinds
of things I'm open to all kinds of
things
hell boy so I'm going to show you this
video Gabe's going to join us here in
about 15 minutes but I want to show you
this video of Ron DeSantis what sounds
like a closing argument to me
um this sounds like what Rhonda Santa's
closing argument in the primary Ruby so
this is right before the primaries would
start with Donald Trump when he's like
60 points behind and and Ron DeSantis is
really really really trying to beg the
voters to vote for him to win in the
first maybe second primary because
really honestly that's what I see
happening Ron DeSantis is going to go in
the first primer and they get [__]
his clock clean he's going the second
one lose even worse go to the third one
and probably bow out right before the
third one
because he thinks he's going to save his
political career and he thinks he's
going to save his chance for 2028 he
won't have a shot in Hell he's done
you're done son you're done and you're
done because you're doing stupid [__]
like this on Fox and Friends where
you're giving what sounds like a closing
argument with Trump
and it you're it's only been a week man
and you're making closing arguments are
you [__] me this is this is horrible
listen that's right now the time for Ron
DeSantis to run for president
because uh everyone knows if I'm the
nominee I will beat Biden uh and I will
serve two terms and I will be able to uh
destroy leftism in this country and
leave woke ideology on the Dustbin of
History
woke ideology so not only does he want
to get rid of people who have ideas on
the Left Right leftists destroy them by
the way
he says he says he wants to leave wokism
in the dustpan history
um he means black people I don't know if
you know that I don't know if you know
what woke means but it means black
people that's what it means
that's what it means
to Mr Ron meatball DeSantis it's really
it really is it really is
um great when they say the quiet part
out loud and he speaks like a true Nazi
he really does it's [__] crazy ass
[__] crazy ass [__]
but there is there is Ron DeSantis
giving his closing arguments uh for
Trump in his first week of running his
campaign again uh he felt black on his
face
um with the launch on Twitter and he
falls flat again with his little
closing argument there and for four
for trumpism okay so let's go to let's
see
um I think we have some Kevin McCarthy
is trending maybe we'll get are we gonna
get a statement from this chucklehead
this morning I highly doubt it of what
he's gonna say about this deal now he
did say um he did say that something
that really pissed off a lot of the
moglodytes including chip Roy is that
Biden
Biden is great Biden was great at that
oh man
um he's fantastic and he was really
strong and he did these negotiations it
was killer it was killer uh he's not
winning any any uh any allies in his
caucus now here's the thing
if you look at this deal this debt
ceiling deal and I know a lot of people
on the left may be a little outraged
about the the the SNAP benefit we have
to understand about the concession that
the that Biden made for the SNAP benefit
is this
it's not snap all together right the
qualifier is not snapped from age 49 to
54. the only thing they did was change
the work requirement and not only did
they just change the work requirement
from 49 to 54. so what basically what
that means is right now anyone over 49.
anyone over 49 are under 40s 49 or under
excuse me has a work requirement on SNAP
benefits anyone over doesn't they move
that age to 54. now what they did do
what they did do is get exemptions
which they move the mark of what
veterans the veterans exemption from the
work requirement actually means and they
moved it in favor of veterans not
against it and they also moved it for
the homeless
and people who are disabled so
so this arbitrary number where they
moved 49 to 54 for the work requirement
really they didn't move it at all
because all the exceptions takes away
any work requirement that someone from
49 to 54 may have the majority the
majority the one thing they did do
that is going to help Americans the most
that Republicans have been hell-bent on
Americans not receiving student debt
relief
but that is one thing that they have
cooked into this bill that there's going
to be handfuls of Republicans that are
going to vote for it
and against it
which I don't care if Republicans vote
for it are against it I don't care which
one they're voting which way they vote
um the main thing is is we have to
politicize the [__] out of this that's
what we have to do we have to politicize
the [__] out of these in the in these
general election races or we have these
incumbent Republicans who either voted
for student debt relief now think about
this for a second you're like Tony how
can we weaponize that against them we
weaponize that against them with their
constituents the people who were told
that student debt relief is for a bunch
of lazy wokers they're for a bunch of
lazy motherwokers
heaven heaven under underwater basket
weaving and gender identity
degrees and then colleges and
universities
so we can hold it against them with
their constituents which is very
important that that way that way we can
drive that wedge
and get those voters to reconsider now
which that's going to be fought
partially in the primary that's the
beauty of the primary now how do we how
do we how do we take advantage of this
if they voted against it well that's
obvious they voted against the American
people
you don't you don't think that folks in
purple districts are swing districts or
districts that we can run we can run a
Democrat and could do that absolutely
we can do that we can draw those wedge
so think about think about this this
debt ceiling um deal not as such a deal
as as in Joe Biden saved
um an economic crisis number one but
number two he pushed the budget past the
next election
we're gonna get it passed right and
there's no debt ceiling until after
so it's up to you to engage in your
democracy to make sure we never have to
have this debt ceiling fight in 2025
2026. that's the beauty of this that's
the groundwork that he has laid before
us and he did it masterly without having
to [__] run laps and brag and he's
the greatest president of all time and
I'm the president of all presidents he
doesn't have to do that type of [__] and
the reason why is because he understands
how Washington Works he's got a steady
hand he's and he's proved that in this
[__] debate
or excuse me in this negotiation he's
proven that he's had a steady hand and
then he's going to fight for the
American people
and that's going to be proven in in and
out of his the next year and a half of
his presidency
as Kevin McCarthy has just given up
every [__] single negotiating point
that he absolutely has think about it
I was saying two months ago that if they
if they [__] didn't do this debt
ceiling and they pushed this into
September where they are going to have
to they were going to have to put Kick
the Can down the road
for for another for another [__] year
for the budget Kevin McCarthy was not
going to be speaker
Joe Biden knew that Joe Biden knew that
yes I'm gonna I'm Gonna Keep Kevin
McCarthy as the speaker because he is
easy he's easy he doesn't know [__] he's
dumb sumbitch and Joe Biden can
manipulate him okay
yes yes it it Joe Biden is not some
[__] feeble man who doesn't know what
he's doing he knows exactly what he's
doing
he knows exactly what he's doing he
knows exactly how the government works
he knows exactly how these negotiation
Congress Works he knows exactly what
Mitch McConnell moves Mitch McConnell is
going to make and what moves he's not
going to make he knows exactly how to
play Kevin McCarthy and the manga
Republicans in the house like a fiddle
and this negotiation Bears it out now
again my
my view is
that we should 14th this thing but I'm
not the [__] president you didn't
vote for me
I'm not the guy sitting in the chair Joe
Biden is
but he did a damn good job of again
laying laying the groundwork that we
need to politicize these issues to win
for democracy next year all the way down
the ballot
because it's not just about his race
and he knows it
he knows he has to get Democrats to win
he knows to have a successful second
term as president he has to have the
house back he needs to have Governors on
his side he needs to make sure that in
these red States they don't have super
majorities
and he's laying it right out in front of
you to go yep he's right let's take it
up let's pick up democracy and let's run
with it he's giving us that opportunity
with with this debt ceiling deal and
that's why that is exactly why Democrats
are not going to push back too hard on
this you're gonna you're gonna feel a
little pushback because they're going to
want to get some people who on the left
are a little riled up about this they
didn't get exactly what they wanted
not exactly you know the extremist on
the left are like on the right if they
don't get exactly 100 what they want
then it's a bad deal which is really
stupid in democracy and in a republican
General really dumb I mean I'm not
excited about everything in this deal
I mean I think the Republicans got their
asses handed to them because they're
they're they're stupid they're dumb as
[__] they made they made this argument
about how the debt ceiling is a credit
card which it is not they did this with
lies and when they continue to negotiate
with lies and lie to the American people
and lie to their constituency and lie
about the process of how it works and
the process isn't how it works they're
gonna get [__] had every single time
especially by Joe Biden who knows
exactly how the process works and this
is the dumb [__] that like tyt does to
their [__] audience and you can
[__] hate me for knocking on them but
they lie to you they lie to you about
how the process works when they say that
Marianne Williamson has a chance of
winning in a Democratic party you are
not a serious [__] commentator you
are not either that or you're [__]
lying intentionally to your audience one
of the two
you either don't know your head from a
hole in the ground
and you don't know what reality is okay
and you can [__] like I'm saying I
want him the 14th but I know it's not
realistic and I'm telling you he's not
going to 14th and I want him to so we
don't have to have this fight but it's
not realistic he doesn't have to now
he doesn't at the 14th so he's not going
to
but when tyt says [__] like and
commentators on tyt are supporters of
Marianne Williamson get on tyt and say
stupid [__] about Marianne Williamson
you don't know how it works
it's the dumbest stupid [__] I've heard
of in my [__] life again you either
not a serious commentator
you don't know your you don't know [__]
from Shinola in American politics and
elections or you're lying to your
audience intentionally it's one of those
three it's one of those three
if you're talking about Marianne
Williamson being in the Democratic
primary right and you're only hurting
yourself you're not you're not helping
yourself
you're hurting yourself just like when
Republicans use lies to [__] talk
about this [__] like this target thing
and the Bud Light thing and the [__]
Disney thing the wokism and all this
nonsense this absolute [__] that
they the lies that they spew
they're only hurting themselves
because eventually people realize
they're full of [__] [__] you're just
full of [__] [__] is all you are
Rhonda scientist really isn't a war with
Disney he can't be in a war with Disney
it would destroy Florida if he destroyed
Disney okay bottom line that's just how
it would [__] work
and you don't have to have more than a
couple brain cells to rub together to
understand that
but it's lies he's lying well again
three things he's either not serious as
not and not a serious politician right
he doesn't know how it [__] works and
he's a bonehead or or he's lying to his
constituency my guess is Rhonda santis
is a little bit of all three but mostly
lying to his constituency or his
audience
dumb [__] uh Sue B here says um Miriam
Williamson on YouTube she says William
doesn't have a snowball's chance in hell
she might as well not even try to run in
fact she's not even a Democrat well I
mean all those are good arguments
those are all good arguments of why
Marion and Williamson
no one should even have her name in
their mouth especially if you're giving
political commentary on the 2024
election if you're giving commentary and
you're trying to get people to take you
seriously and you're like Marianne
Williamson is the best candidate out
there you are not a serious commentator
you are not
you're [__] again you're either
bone-headed and you don't know how it
works or you're [__] lying to your
audience one way or the other it's just
there's no way out of it so when you
hear someone put their that [__] name
or RFK which he is a [__] manga plant
by the way
RFK is a manga blant he's a trump plant
in the Democratic primary there's no way
he's gonna win either but listen this is
not how Democratic primaries work
uh Republican and Democratic primaries
as a national party are set up that the
incumbent President right the head of
the party the highest position that you
can hold in an incumbent office in this
country
under those parties right
you only get two terms that's it you get
two chances at it that's it that's why
Donald Trump running again
in this weird [__] reality where a
lot of these [__] think he won
but he didn't he [__] lost believe
he's running for a third win
it's incumbency to some degree for him
that's why Ron DeSantis is starting
behind
but folks it doesn't matter Republican
or Democrat
the incumbent president
gets the nomination
they get the nomination that that is how
the Party primary
is arranged when you win your your
primary and you get the nomination and
you win
the the Office of the President in the
United States you were afforded another
chance at a second term that's what
that's just how it works in both parties
Republican and Democrat
there's it's set up that way actually
it's set up that way now
when you have people out there not
adhering to those facts those simple set
of facts you have people who are doing
commentary that is dumb as dog [__]
it's there is no Universe where there's
going to be a democratic Challenger
because the Democratic party is smarter
than the Republican party in this manner
to give our president our incumbent
president the right to run
and do not have a Challenger
they're the head of the party they won
they have the chance now you can argue
with me all day long you want it
shouldn't be that way wow we need to
change it we need to do this we need to
do that yeah okay great fine you you can
change it but it and
when
you're gonna change it tomorrow
you think Joe Biden's gonna wake up
tomorrow like you know what you're right
you're right we should change it we just
we're just gonna change the whole
process I'm gonna let someone primary me
we'll do that
I don't know if you know this but Bernie
Sanders actually changed how the super
delegates
are figured
if if you want to talk about change and
how much change the left has made on the
left Bernie Sanders made a lot of change
to the super delegates not enough to
make a difference for an incumbent
president and again if you don't know
that then you don't know [__] from
Shinola and you don't know how elections
and primaries work
but that's fine that's fine
but again they're just lying and that is
the problem with the right is all they
do is lie they lie lie lie lie lie and
they continue to lie and it's going to
continue to hurt them in the long term
yeah they might get a short-term little
[__] hissy fit from the right
about Bud Light or pride shirts at
Target or Kohl's having to display
whatever the [__] their little stupid
culture Ward The Little Mermaid is black
oh my God
Disney's woke because the little mermaid
a fictional characters black now instead
of white it really it really upsets my
feelings this is really stupid [__] this
is short-term stuff that they're trying
to stoke Outreach
and they continue to try to do this with
the culture wars that that they've lost
anyways you've already lost this culture
War the majority of Americans are not
upset the Disney cast
a black woman as The Little Mermaid a
fictional character they're not upset go
look at the ticket sales that will tell
you they're not that upset
it's [__] ridiculous they're
boneheads but let them keep doing it
again don't take the shovel out of their
hands when they're digging their
political grade folks don't do that
Gabe Sanchez is going to join us here in
a minute some people were asking where
he's at
I don't know it's Memorial Day he said
he'd be here and if he isn't then it'd
just be me and you right so what the
hell's the difference right
Edward on YouTube says real real
mermaids are white Tony it's just
science uh Edward
um he's got the best ones uh thanks for
always being here and commenting you
know what I'm gonna go over and check
out twitch for a second hang on I want
to go check out twitch we've had um
oh man I I tell you we've had a lot of
support we just got over 1200 followers
on Twitch it's free to follow us on
Twitch did you know that it's free
but it does it does give us a little bit
um to get subscriptions subscriptions
are a little different and I gotta be
honest with you we're down right now
we're down on our subs here's why we're
down on our subs our subscriptions over
there is because you you have probably
linked your Prime account
to your Twitch account
and if you have linked your Prime
account to your Twitch account you
haven't renewed your subscription this
month that's what you have to do if you
have if you have linked those two
together your Amazon Prime account to
your Twitch account you have to go in
and re-subscribe every month I know it's
a little bit of work
I know but we're down we're down about
50 60 subscribers right now today which
means that folks just haven't remembered
to go in and resub which is fine that's
great now is the opportunity now is the
correct time to go in and to
re-subscribe with your Twitch account if
it's already linked to your Amazon Prime
account no problem it's quick it's quick
and if you don't know how to do it just
get in the twitch chat they're gonna
tell you how to do it and thank you
um Shadow woman seven she's gifting some
monthly Subs out to people here uh on
Twitch
and several people have resubscribed
um to twitch but you gotta you gotta do
it every month and I think they send an
email is what they do
is what they do so just just go into uh
twitch and rather you go to twitch.tv
slash the Tony Michaels that's twitch.tv
slash the Tony Michaels or just go to
twitch.tv and search the Tony Michaels
and you'll find the show there now get
in the chat with the folks if you need
to know exactly how to resubscribe or to
link your Prime account here's how you
do it you go to the Tony michaels.com
that's thetonymichaels.com there's a
link about four down it says link your
Amazon account to your Twitch account
when you link those two then you can
give us that one free subscription that
you get with prime because that's the
thing here that's how we get paid with
the Prime account is you give us one
free subscription
that one free subscription you get with
your Amazon Prime account you link it to
your Twitch and you give us that one
free subscription and we get a few
dollars
of Amazon's money every single month so
we thank you there also why on YouTube
you might as well subscribe too why not
hit that subscribe button it's free to
subscribe on YouTube that's what's
really weird so on Twitch it's free to
follow
but you pay money to subscribe on
YouTube it's free to subscribe it's
really weird each one's different each
one's different that's like on Twitter
you follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod and then and then you don't
you can subscribe and follow us on my
Apple Spotify Google for the audio
version but you download the audio
version
you download it see and there's all this
stuff that you know it's weird that's
why you don't a lot of people are
talking about Discord and we've got a
Discord server if you want to go see our
Discord server you go to the Tony
michaels.com that link is on the way on
the on my web page there the
tonymichaels.com you can find the
Discord
I don't know [__] about Discord though
is the problem that's the horrible thing
about it that's a horrible thing about
it all right I'm gonna take a quick
break when we come back we're going to
talk a little more hopefully Gabe
Sanchez will be joining us soon everyone
stick around we'll be right back right
after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product part in blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
Luanne from Facebook says we need new
commercials that we've got those
memories I know I cycle did the same
ones I need to pull out the uh the
boycott binder well that would be great
right now Gabe had won a while back
called boycott binder maybe I'll pull
that one out
put it on the rotation there Luanne for
boycott binder that's when we haven't
watched in a while
um here's the thing is that we're
actually going to I believe start having
um some affiliate sponsors for some
commercials so you guys are going to
have the opportunity to give us support
that way too
um um we've been in talks with Lumi so
hopefully we'll
we'll work that out soon it's just a
process it takes a while for these
things to happen
and we have a few other uh brands in
mind that we're gonna do uh
affiliate commercials a lot of Joy Lee
says the uhile commercial
see the problem with the UL commercial
uh is I really if we play it too much we
may um
we may piss off U-Haul I mean I get you
know [__] it what's the big difference
right maybe it'll be a badge of honor to
piss off U-Haul so much that they send
me a cease and desist I don't know
but the problem the problem is if I play
it too much they may
um do a cease and desist and then what
they'll do and because it is brand if we
do it too much it might be considered um
brand defamation or at least they could
claim that right which they could claim
that with YouTube and then all the
episodes that have it in there give
gonna be taken off YouTube so I don't
know maybe we'll do it now and now and
again I don't know and thanks for coming
on this Memorial Day Joey Leaf it's
great to see you
a lot of people like the um
is you all woke Tony TB says you all
will not see there you all commercial
that Gabe did
um and I believe it's on his YouTube
channel probably it's about Patriot
front and how um it's always
my Discord link isn't working
okay I have to go [__] look at it I
don't know
just how much I pay attention to Discord
I guess
but that you all you all isn't woke it's
that you all
always appears to be the the
um
the Preferred Truck Rental of Nazis
whether it be Patriot front or like the
guy from Missouri who tried to Ram the
barricade to get to the White House last
week
um Joy Leaf says but it's parody yeah I
know
I know
we've talked about putting it on maybe
we should maybe we should uh
here we go it's not Tony oh it keeps
sending the stream labs
what stream labs the the link on on my
hang on a second God damn it
hang on let me let's let's see let's see
if we can fix this
okay all right here's a website be
tonymichaels.com right
here we are here's the website
if you want to see it this is this is
the website that has and what I do every
day if you don't know this like at the
very top this top this top link that's
Today's Show I don't always get it up
there in time that's one reason why I
was late today because I was putting it
up but you see it as part of the
thumbnail and that's the link so that
goes directly to the show on YouTube
that's the YouTube link okay for the
show it's the very top every single day
and then you get the patreon link here
and it wiggles and jiggles to get your
attention for support on patreon because
again that's that's how we did and
here's the tip jar if you guys are
wondering how um because we're not
monetized on YouTube because they
[__] hate my guts
um but if you want to give like a super
chat now you won't get credit for it
because it's not in the chat so people
won't see it but if you want to give a
tip if you're used to giving super chats
and that's how you want to support the
show there's a tip jar right here that's
where you leave it and me and Gabe split
those as like super chats right and we
get more of it so YouTube doesn't take a
cut so we actually get more of the money
you actually give us in this tip jar
here so if you like to give a super
chance that's the place to do it here's
the Amazon link Twitch account
um for like linking your Amazon and
twitch and if you click on that it'll
take you to the page to do it here's the
merch stores which were I I think this
afternoon we're gonna get the rake merch
up anyone listening rake merch the surf
this afternoon okay
um
down here is the Discord server we're
gonna see what happens when I click this
thing
invite invalid of course
I've I don't know
how'd that happen I I didn't show it
because it pops up another window and I
just had this one window so I gotta fix
that I'm sorry I'm sorry I gotta fix it
I gotta fix it I'll try to fix it later
and figure out what we got
[Music]
um
oh DJ fox says just the tip that's right
if you want to get put just the tip in
if you want to put just the tip in
there's the tip jar on the Tony Michaels
podcast you just go to the Tony
michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com all the social medias here
too
um here is the um
the um
oh here's the podcast Twitter if you
want to vote for bonehead that's that
link there
but this is my Twitter account down
below so all the stuff there Gabe
Sanchez's merch store link is on there
so it's all there you guys should go to
the website
and um check it out again if you're if
you if you don't have the link to the
show every day you just can go to
thetonymichaels.com and at the very top
this is the link right here at the very
top I usually some days I fail most days
I'm successful at getting Today's Show
at the very top of that at the very top
of that so you can always go to
just go to the Tony michaels.com so
there's your tour
of the Tony michaels.com and I found out
that yes
yes
it
um
it is not working the Discord link so
I'll um
I'll go check it out today thanks for
keeping me
thanks for keeping me up to speed on
that day
oh Gabe Gabe Gabe Gabe Gabe Gabe Gabe I
I know I'm waiting for him what do you
want from me
what do you want from me I don't mean
let me tell them they are begging
for you
there I told them you're bacon oh there
he is that's about goddamn time
they either they're banging for you all
right all right it was I I heard it I
heard it yeah is that why I heard it and
then I was summoned by Bossman in Texas
okay yeah that's true that's true all
right we'll see you guys later Gabe
changes
this is great so anyway I was telling
the audience next Monday and Tuesday
you're gonna run the show yeah um are
you so are you prepared to do the first
the a block 30 minutes of ranting I mean
it's just gonna be me talking who knows
what I'm gonna talk about man why I mean
depending on what the news of the day is
by then I know I know because you know I
sometimes it's weird because like if
we're like down to the wire like this
morning it was you were like uh debt
ceiling I'm like nah [__] that that's
kind of old yeah yeah that's done uh I
wanted to do I really wanted to have
Trump with his attacking um right right
as his statement that's really where I
wanted to go with it yeah because I
wanted to play the clip of Ron DeSantis
talking about how he's going to destroy
leftism uh left ideology and woke up he
also he also did it and still didn't say
Donald Trump's name no well I mean he's
he can't he can't attack Trump and the
reason why he can't is because he'll
lose what's crazy to me about the video
of him this morning on Fox and Friends
is it feels like a closing argument
right it doesn't feel like an opening
argument it feels like a clue he's like
look the reason why you should vote for
me is because I'm gonna beat Joe Biden
and I have two turns and I'm gonna I'm
gonna eradicate lefties like whoa dude
that sounds like a closing argument not
really sounds a lot like a Nazi too wow
I'm gonna you know speak I I said spoken
like a true Nazi that was my response to
it this morning let me uh let me go back
I want to show you
um this statement let's see if I can
find it from Grandpa yeah you got it you
got it there uh I could get it yeah
let's hide this comment from boss man
Texas it's kind of I don't know it's
offensive I kind of like it
all right I got it I got it right here
oh by the way I apparently the Discord
link on on the website is [__] up so I
gotta go fix that today yeah we were we
were taking a tour what the [__] are you
laughing at this guy's always like
Boomer Boomer you're like I just missed
the https right yeah I don't know what
the hell happened okay so here's the
here's the statement from True social
we're having fun today it's a holiday
wanna let's see so here is here's
Grandpa's little rant what do you want
to call this this is [__] weird man
uh
uh he's it's just it's whenever whenever
these this is you know it reminds me of
the Mother's Day one where he's like
happy Mother's Day
also like it's just like yes he can't
just say happy moral yeah he's like hey
happy it's like happy Mother's Day oh oh
or like uh Happy Memorial Day to all of
our veterans out there who serve our
country and put their lives on the line
right that's all you got to say all you
gotta say right right you can just do
the cookie cutter thing to get by
whenever there is a holiday or some
event that happens he will use it as an
excuse to start it as like a happy this
day right and then there's like a dot
dot dot and he's like well I'm already
typing so [__] it I might as well well I
mean do you think this is do you think
this is Donald Trump playing 12d chest
as his supporters think he's like 165 D
chest man right at this point yeah
that's where he's at where he's like
where they're like he's just like you
know what I'm gonna tie this insane rant
to a memorial day so everyone talks
about how crazy I am at this point and
he thinks that's a good thing for like a
general election yeah it's for people
who think he's a total [__] Luna I
mean it starts with happy Memorial Day
and it ends with communist marxists and
fascist pigs right like what how like
they're it's weird the leaps though I
mean we can read it you know well I mean
do we really have to I don't know I mean
here look we put it on the [__]
thumbnail happy Memorial Day
and then the middle is stopping the
threats of terrorists Misfits and
lunatic thugs
and then it goes down to communist
Marxist and fascists also this guy he
doesn't believe in the Oxford comma
Shame
Shame Shame Shame it's
ah the guy's a lunatic and if this is
his sporty chess to show the world that
he's a lunatic more power to him really
go for it I'm surprised that he hasn't
uh
that he hasn't made fun of Ron
desantis's tagline yet the Great
American comeback
honestly you did call him Rob uh let me
let me see right now sanctimonious let
me go to that one because and and then
he played a video here here's here's his
shirt oh I haven't watched that video I
saw that he put a 40 27 points it's just
it's just Rhonda Santa's [__] licking
Donald Trump oh a Lou Dobbs show okay
right it's just it's just Ron DeSantis
licking his balls that's it
um here is here's here's Trump going
after this what's that true social ad
um what the [__] cardiologist too much
belly fat oh okay do this before bed
what do what before bed don't click the
link man you're gonna get some virus
[Laughter]
okay so
um here's here's his attack this morning
on on Rob and even puts Robin quotes now
so Ron the sanctimonious just stated it
without correction on Fox and Friends
that I was backing Disney wrong
um Fox should have read my post-truth
posted truth on Disney but that's not
the game they play oh [__]
also in the polls I'm beating Biden by a
lot Rob literally in quotes isn't
also way up on Ron does any of this make
sense when you're reading it no I I I
still don't understand how he got to Rob
like did he mistype oh you know what I
think happened yeah look at your
keyboard where's the b in connection
with the end he he so he mistyped he
mistyped robs when he was like rage yeah
yeah so he mistyped Ron and typed Rob
and now I think he's trying to
he's like that one [__] guy from
Missouri who's like huh I knew it was a
parody account right oh you're talking
about Ben yeah I think what's happened
here is he hit he he meant to hit n and
the fat finger on the phone hit B and
then so now he's like oh yeah now it's
Rob so now he's like trying to he's like
I meant to do that I yeah that was
intentional but he's like check out
those distinct distinctive speech at
Trump rally I gave to get him elected
not easy P.S got 1.2 more million more
votes in Florida than Ron a little
reported fact oh really you've never
mentioned that before dummy Jesus Christ
he brings it up and every [__] Tweety
tweets about raw Rob Jesus Christ but
here's here's the here's the uh let's
see
here's the [__] thing about Disney
okay
so they're trying to really straddle the
fence here right both of them because
here's his the tweet that he says Fox
News won't read right he says Disney has
become awoke and disgusting shadow of
its former self with people actually
hating it I mean the people who are told
in your cult to hate it now they hate it
is that what you're saying because
that's what it feels like you're saying
he's he goes on to no one ever had a
problem with any of these companies hey
can you can you go look up what the
number one movie in the country is right
now
it's probably gonna be like Fast X
honestly let's go look it up
um must go back to what it was once was
or the market will do irreparable damage
then that's what the market does why are
these people who claim
[__] no well yes no these box office
numbers are woke as [__] man what's the
box office numbers
[Laughter]
The Little Mermaid I know it is
925.4 million gross nope that that that
is fake news there's no way that Disney
sold that many tickets to that movie
here's like can I give you and you know
what the third one is what's that
Guardians of the Galaxy whoa whoa whoa
who owns Marvel
so they're number one number three how
many what's the ticket sales for Marvel
I mean just on those two alone yeah
that's just on this weekend I'm over
here well here actually you know what
total gross right now for a little
mermaid 95.4 million
to what 100 million bucks yeah yeah and
the total gross for Guardians of the
Galaxy 3
300 million bucks oh man 400 so a half a
billion dollars it sounds like there's a
sinking ship over there
the number one and number three movie in
the country when there's a huge writer
strike oh man and there's a huge boycott
of dizzy I'm telling you man no one's
seeing Disney Disney's a sink it's that
woke disgusting it I mean I'm trying to
say actually I'm trying to find are
there any other like people like oh
that's a right wing
like
I don't know I don't know also and then
not only that and then you still got
Ant-Man and the WASP which I guess is
still playing at some places and that
[__] made 200 almost 215 million
dollars
oh my God by the end of the week man
just from those three million over the
weekend no no no no oh I'm sorry
I don't know they uh but by the end of
the week all three of these movies will
probably clear close to a billion
dollars in total man that sounds like a
sinking ship to me
crazy wow that sucks for Disney
um
oh man okay I just thought of an idea I
don't want to put it online now oh okay
yeah it does save it put a note make a
note somewhere someone will steal it and
here's here's the crazy part because I
went to see Little Mermaid now I'm not
gonna ruin it for anybody
um and it's hard to ruin these
live-action movies because if you've
seen the cartoon
you're you're probably gonna know a
little bit that's gonna happen with the
live action right now out of all the
live actions that I've seen this is
probably
the least of them that I would have paid
money to go see now just because I
didn't feel like
um I'm trying not to I'm trying not to
spoil this for people because you want
to go see okay what about it you can you
say it's like is it okay here's what
here's what it was effects here's what
it was no no no it wasn't the art and
that's one thing about the live action
that kind of like I think it's
denigrating to call these lime action
because it's like discounts all the
[__] animators because 95 of this
movie is animated yeah yeah right it's
just not [__] drawn on a piece of
paper right like a like a a cartoon
you're telling me these people aren't
talking underwater right it's really
[__] weird man and I can't believe
that they didn't grow the mermaid tails
anyways the point is this is that it's
not really live action I mean it is but
it's not yeah okay it's partly live
action right right yeah
here's the thing is that
in this lime action movie
there is not the component of flounder
to Tick-Tock through the story right and
you don't really understand how flounder
is so
um important to the story of the cartoon
that you are so familiar with I haven't
seen in years so I totally forget right
and you may want to go watch the cartoon
beforehand I didn't but you may want to
um because you can really tell because
they didn't have flounders this integral
part and it's almost like her sidekick
right right right I mean he is there but
he's not really the sidekick
um it just it doesn't the story doesn't
flow and doesn't tell like it told in
the in the cartoon version that's my
opinion that now the animation [__]
fantastic yeah phenomenal the the under
the sea that scene where they do that
music oh my God [__] just so good man
I I don't know how long it probably took
them and how many people worked on that
one that one song at the end animation
part but it's phenomenal kiss the girl
the animation that [__] phenomenal so
the animation in it the actual animation
like the art is [__] great
um the live action part is good too it
just I didn't feel like they tied the
plot together and it to my feeling was
that it was the lack of that character
flounder yeah it didn't tie it all
together that's my opinion you should
still go see it you definitely should
give Disney your money just to piss
these [__] off just go give the
mouse your money rather it's right
[__] little mermaid or Gardens again
I mean look the mouse the mouse
technically gets my money every month
I pay rent well yeah well actually it's
in a way because it's part of my phone
plan so they're like oh do you want ESPN
Hulu Disney plus like it's all the
package kind of thing so like by paying
my phone bill like I also get that as a
result so I'm paying the mouse
regardless that's true Barbara here says
on Facebook says don't spoil it but is
the mermaid wet you [__] dirty sons
of [__] man in the chat we love you
you guys minds are always in the gutter
hey we we were like two days without
talking about porn now here we are we
went so long you know it's so long like
I would love I would love to see
Republicans or right-wing um people fly
to Denmark
because you know what's in Denmark go
ahead there's a there's a Little Mermaid
statue that's really yeah yeah I
actually went there is it based on the
Disney Little Mermaid or the the Angry
no it's based on the story it's well
it's based on the the the performance
the ballet performance at the Royal
Danish theater in Copenhagen but like I
went there in 2000
2016. 2016 I think I went to Iceland and
I went to oh okay I went to uh Stockholm
and Copenhagen all these different spots
how was Iceland that's pretty cool that
was great we we took uh my partner and I
we got a van and drove all around
Iceland in a week by the river just made
me think of that pretty much
um it was a ton of fun man beautiful
beautiful had my drone I flew it over
the water over the waterfalls I went
chasing waterfalls it was amazing
and that
in that moment I was like I'm not gonna
listen to the song I'm Gonna Do the
opposite of the song I'm Gonna Change
this thing do you what song says a ton
of fun ton of fun it was great I highly
recommend okay so so what about the
limit did you see the Little Mermaid
statue I mean you can Google it right
now and you can find it right did you
get a picture with it yeah yeah we got a
picture it's right there on the water
Bank okay I get it yeah on the Promenade
I guess it would call it but yeah oh
fancy [__] yeah I know European is that
yeah is that European
pretty much and then I was like I'm
gonna have a Danish while I'm in Denmark
oh my god oh [__] they probably thought
you were just all around just a American
Square there when you're like with my
Danish on the Promenade in the in the
thingy thing on the year being back
trapping trip I don't know it's Monday
wow uh okay so um it looks like Jesus
um Christ is alive is trending
I'm sure what the [__] is this oh boy
what the hell is this why is it is it
trending oh maybe this is maybe this is
what it is
um this Meme here it says uh love
everyone no matter what
what if they do drag yes even if they
ask stupid questions you should still
love them
maybe that's why maybe that's why maybe
I mean it's you know every time I was
like cancel them burn them at the stake
take them down you know what's funny I
saw a video uh I don't know if you sent
me the video maybe yesterday it was the
people that were at a concert in Ohio
um oh yes yes right and they were and
they were there was a you know there's a
fair amount of Bud Light at the top yet
there were still people I saw one guy
pick up a bud wiser can you send that to
me did I or can you no can you send that
to me I don't think I sent it to you but
I think
I think I've seen it can you send it to
me and then there's another uh video uh
of another concert
and I forget the artist's name at this
point but they're like oh if you voted
for Rhonda Santos you can go [__]
yourself or you're dead to me is what
she said someone's got the link to that
one yeah someone's got the link to that
and they can send it to it too
um we're just [__] around here today
today's the holiday we're glad that you
guys are joining us though
and I promise we're gonna get all these
glitches uh fixed hey look at that you
guys really listen so our subscriber
count was down on Twitch because not as
many people have re-subscribed
um I told them hey you probably should
go resubscribe and they're they're doing
it thank you very much thank you thank
you
okay so what do you got here this is the
one that's the other one let's see let's
get it going here look at that link
click I did link it up okay so this is
where is this at oh a George Strait
concert even better yeah Columbus Ohio
oh man that's right so we got some we
got some American flag gear of course oh
look at this look at these two
chuckleheads what do they got these guys
what's a manly drink Well here here's
the thing is that you don't know this
but oh sometimes woke companies make
unwoke beer like Anheuser-Busch they
make Bud Light which is a totally woke
beer and if you even look at it if you
look at it you may it may Turn You Gay
but Michelob Ultra don't Tony don't you
dare tell me they're owned by some
company Michelob Ultra is owned by the
same company
so these guys are drinking woke non-woke
beer but let's let's see what happens in
the in the in the video here see all
right so we got Anheuser-Busch product
nothing nothing maybe a lot of water oh
there we go go back go back
go back to the guy right there oh yeah
yeah boom that guy he's got an anhyzer
he's got a Budweiser straight mud so
that's Anheuser-Busch so we got four
beers
four four beers Anheuser-Busch okay
there's a lot of Bud Light that hasn't
been touched yet but if you have a
feeling like somebody's gonna grab it
okay let's watch
grab him by the Bud Light here all right
so we've got some uh
white claws oh there we go
what is a five so there's some there's a
water some white Claws and that guy
right there boom he Zooms in on him
because he's like oh man I'm gonna get
this guy
this guy got a bloodline I think so or
he got to make a low volume
the funniest part is all this is
Anheuser-Busch besides the white claw
yeah that's pretty good I mean what are
they thinking and you know what's funny
about all this
look at the [__] coolers you see the
coolers no the no coolers that they're
in are coolers Light coolers so not all
so they tried to trick these
[__] as well George Strait is
trying to trick his audience he's like
look they're not gonna drink the woke
beer if we put it in a cooler that says
Cooler's light it'll totally confuse
them no totally confused him so what
you're saying what what this video
actually tells me
is this is that people who drink beer
are just going to drink beer because if
you look at this shelf here like this
one here has Bud Light in the middle
shelf and on the top shelf but if you
look down okay so there's Bud Light on
the middle shelf here and
and they're paying for this space in
these coolers imagine you see this one
here now it's empty that one there I
would bet that there was Bud Light on
that shelf yep just going based off of
uh the layout here like it's not like
again for same thing over here this
one's empty right here I would say that
this was probably Bud Light or Bud Light
it was a woman she's like don't you dare
don't you dare dude
oh here's another shelf behind this
little well little yeah what is this
game what he's got a shirt another and
he's got Bud Lights it looks like but
there's there's an empty shelf behind
this
um this is the moment of like oh [__]
I've been caught
oh no the face you make when you know
you've been caught on camera that is
he's got Bud Light he's got two of them
he's got two of them
this is all so stupid
did you see that that that Kohl's is
that these you know Kohl's in Walmart
has a bright display on your whole month
yeah no yeah damn it uh I know you can't
shop at Walmart can't shop at Kohl's
apparently you can't buy a Tesla can't
buy a Tesla support Elon Musk in SpaceX
anymore yeah yeah yeah and it's also
like oh the company that that was
started by
uh Elon musk's cousins and acquired by
Elon Musk you know with Tesla was also
pretty [__] woke right they were an
official sponsor SolarCity before being
acquired by Tesla was an official
sponsor of the SF pride parade what what
is what is the SF Pride rate it sounds
like something that
um is woke
describe the SF it's hours have you been
to it yeah many years I lived in SF for
seven years give us a sense of what
happens okay I mean it's pretty standard
uh but you have a big long pretty pretty
standard antibi wokism yeah yeah right
so you've got Market Street and it runs
cuts the city right in half in terms of
well well Market Street that sounds like
something uh not so woke I mean I don't
know I'm just saying it's pretty it's
pretty standard pretty standard Street
yeah and I'm not convinced yeah but go
ahead we got Market Street right and you
stand on either side and you can get to
the other side by going underneath
through the BART station to get onto one
side to the other right right there are
barricades you stay in there you get
your little pride flags on the stick you
know you wave them around sponsors come
down Market Street with their uh with
their floats and their different
displays people who are running for
office who want to be there other
companies or like hey we got a bus we
got a truck we got a thing we got
whatever it is a float and they got
people going down they got people
dancing they got people singing they got
people [__] throwing t-shirts they
got people [__] throwing candy
whatever it might be super woke stuff
super woke stuff let me tell you I mean
like honestly like I the first year I
was there in 2011 I was not woke oh yeah
and then like a couple months after I
moved there did they forced you to drink
Bud Light dude it was it was insane I
had to drink Bud Light off of a man's
body it was crazy it was insane it was
so woke and it was a lot of fun
well wokism is typically fun right
that's what I think that's what pisses
them off the most is that wokeism is
kind of fun and here's the other thing
too it's like that's not even the
craziest thing if they really want to be
like oh my God all this you know
whatever uh the Folsom Street Fair in
San Francisco way more woke
you got people in BDSM gear you got
people who got yeah they got leather
chap everything man and this caps and
chaps and that is even more fun oh my
God so you're saying the more woke it
gets the more fun it gets the more woke
it is yeah
the more diverse people are there
and the more fun it is okay well I can
tell you that straight up sounds like a
[__] party to me and I'll tell you
this I had never seen anything like that
anyone from Chicago which also has like
another which also has like a pretty big
in terms of like Pride uh uh parades
that are done celebration I think it's
uh
and Coors Light is always like the main
sponsor of it because they're like wait
there's a party and there's gonna be
thousands of people drinking there uh
we're a beer company we'd like to uh
promote that that's what we want to sell
beer
um let's see so Denver Chicago is pretty
big uh obviously your SF New York Miami
right super woke down there whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa
I thought what goes to die in Florida
well
in in in June it's pretty it like like
Jesus Christ man resurrects ow and it's
it's stiff as that that cross I got you
uh but but yeah it's a ton of fun
anytime I've gone to the SF pride in
Chicago where I'm from or SF when I live
there
um always been a blast right well you
know what here I also drove I also drove
through uh West Hollywood yesterday to
go see a friend and man the scene in
West Hollywood was [__] bumping
yesterday man people [__] yeah dude
good looking dudes Bud Light Bud Lights
throwing around everybody everywhere
[__] I mean just raining Bud Light
they probably like water hoses just
spraying
make people gay is that what it is that
what they do they spray it on you to
make it once it hits because I drink it
and I've been trying to drink Bud Light
so that I could
once it hits your lips oh yeah so gay
man okay
oh so they're bitching about Kohl's and
Walmart now being on the pr which they
were gonna be [__] dummies but that
did you hear that about Tractor Supply
the indoctrination and Tractor Supply I
did hear something about Tractor Supply
watch this watch this video here how
they're trying to indoctrinate our
children into being Farmers watch this
I'm here at Tractor Supply and I want to
talk about the tractor agenda that they
have coming for our kids I mean look at
this oh my God look at all these tracks
what the [__] like they are coming for
your oh there's an excavator they are
outrageous
Grandpa's little buddy I don't even want
to know what kind of creepy groomer [__]
that is even believe that they're
putting yellow and green on clothes for
children at all you can say you would
combine the colors red or excuse me
yellow and green on a
on a shirt and then put the words John
Deere in a tractor what do you what the
hell is going on dude I don't I don't
know about you but if I had to guess
John's middle name would be gay RJ games
yeah I think so let's let's let's
continue to see The Grooming that's
happening at Tractor Supply coming for
your kids y'all
you know John Deere's just shoving it
down look at this hat oh my God I'm
using I can't see animals
indoctrinate your children oh my God all
these bright color and Carhartt
to look at this look at this on a baby's
onesie
they're trying to turn all these kids
into Farmers we've got to stand up
against this the farmer agenda did you
see that oh my God this is of course
this is parody this is satire
um because that's real Tony
[Laughter]
did you see uh
hold on let me let me find it yeah
because I think it's I think it's
is it worthy yeah oh yeah always every
single time
uh Brent did a video
uh
the of the target gay display
um and this isn't the whole video
because I think it's like almost three
minutes but this is the we need to get
him back on the show yeah I'd reach out
to him we should we should have him back
on the show we should have him on live
um or something
if he wants to do it from the cart yeah
that would be cool uh in his in his gear
as the as that character
um you know a lot of people saying
Dakota Adams I need to reach out to
Dakota to see if I can get to yeah him
back on the show now that Stuart Rhodes
is sentenced to 18 years he was on
Twitch
um so I went over there while we're
bringing this up what's what's oh this
is uh yeah
they're here it's a great great two
minute and 20 second clip okay so this
gives us insight into the target this is
going to tell you what it's like for is
it gonna break it apart it's it's it
tells you what's going on from a
parent's perspective yeah and what
happens when your child enters a Target
okay let's let's see what happens when
children go into Target that was at
Hooters
watching Fox News do
who's drinking my son comes up to me I I
think he's eight he comes up to me and
he says Daddy can I go over to Target
and play Nintendo switch
and it was just across the parking line
I said you go ahead but you be careful
don't you go near that Bud Light display
two beers later he comes walking into
Hooters
covered head to toe
foreign
all over the place all over that shirt
and they were there were scissors doing
all kinds of this crap on it I don't
even know what that is but I know I
don't like it he walked past the Gay
Pride display at Target and he bought up
every piece of clothing they had with
the no money he makes and not have this
job and he walked over to Hooters he
looked right up at me and he said Daddy
I'm gay now
I'm trans now and Polly and I had to say
it through anger and tears I looked at
him and I said no son of mine's gonna be
gay or trans or a parent and Target it
was within walking distance so I drove
over there I marched right in I found
the first red shirt and khakis I could
find I said hey is this PetSmart and
they said no sir this is Target I said
well if it ain't Pet Smart then why are
y'all grooming in here huh
school shooting or sexual abuse at a
church this is serious this is satanic
and you can't tell by my words and
actions but I'm a Christian you know
what that means it means if I don't like
something everybody else is gonna hear
about it and I'll do everything I can to
be a turd in your punch bowl
you know most people they'd say I I
don't like punch no thank you you go
ahead you enjoy not me
this ain't my party but I'll poop if I
want to so today I'm going to raise my
emotional support being the Target
because you're gonna need it after this
boycott and another
I got so much gay pride glitter in my
lungs Tony
get the pressure washer we're gonna have
to hose this thing down
I didn't know I didn't know I was there
with
with Brent when he was doing it but
apparently I was oh my God that's great
I know and for people who don't I saw
some people who were who were uh asking
if this is real no it's not real so I
know so so Brent is a comedian he lives
out in Indiana yeah and I know Brent
because we did uh we should we have the
same acting teacher together so we had
acting classes and we've had Brent down
the show before as a guest
um you can easily find that interview if
you go to the if you go to the channel
and then type in go to the play yeah
well and I think if you go to the
playlist to have you go to interviews
it's in there too yeah yeah so uh Brent
is hilarious he has a ton of these
videos I mean there are there are there
are videos
that he makes where people are like
wait is this real like there's a part of
it which is like ah I can't quite tell
because it's so good but no this is all
Brent and he's a comedian it's hilarious
yeah it's so good hilarious and he does
he does a lot of stand-up and his
stand-up isn't normally as political as
his yeah mine but he likes to make the
with this character yeah this this car
um character we talked about we talked
with him about it in the interview
um that we did with him so if you want
to go see him talking about this
character and how it came about and and
that sort of thing and then me and him
talk about the difference between uh
redneck and hillbilly yeah
um so we talk about the differences in
that so you go you can go watch that
again just go to just go to the YouTube
channel subscribe first don't forget to
subscribe and then just search in the
search bar Brent or go to the playlist
you'll find it you'll find it
um
okay so so
um there's that one well what do we got
now we have about 10 minutes left what
do we got left any other good news
stories that you want to talk about or
oh I know I know
uh the other night and a Twitter space
um
Matt gatz was watching a Twitter space I
noticed this because I went into
listening in I was listening in and I
seen him listening yeah yeah and then he
goes and starts his own Twitter space
right
and they only ran it for about 30
minutes this is hilarious because they
couldn't even get about a thousand
people in this space but it was him
Lauren bobert and your [__] buddy
your [__] buddy George Santos was in
this room he was in well he was in two
of them actually at the same time no no
no he was in Mario's room first oh what
was he listening or was he speaking he
was speaking and somebody and he didn't
really I mean like he answered some
questions he wasn't really pressed too
hard at the end of the interview
somebody was like why were you why are
you defending why are you defending
miles guo right miles guo connected
together laundry money connected to
Steve Bannon uh uh uh he's a paid
right-wing operative yeah who lives in
Malaysia indicted indicted by the doj uh
and and uh
and George Santos has this theory that
as soon as he started asking questions
about why the doj went after miles guo
then the doj was coming after uh George
Santos which is so crazy to think but
he thinks that's the reason why well
George Santos appeared on Jeopardy did
you know this he's a fighter in Japan
here's here is here is a clip from
Jeopardy uh recent events eight
subheads and a piece on this New York
rep lied about where he went to college
allegedly swindled a disabled vet whose
dog was dying
Mateo who's George Santos I don't get to
say this very much but George Santos is
correct
bam dude he was blocking everyone on
Twitter who shared this clip Ken
Jennings absolutely wads but not you're
Santa's up in the and throws him in the
trash not only that but the fact that
like it was the perfect person to ask
the question back who is George Santos
there was no but like there was never a
better Moment In Time a never better a
never a better promise or a premise a
situation in which that question would
be asked because everyone's like you
know I I do my bits where I'm like who
the [__] is George Santos right and in
this show
this is the perfect you're like well
that's the answer Santa is George Santos
who who is George Santos and then the
follow-up is I don't get to say this
very much but George Santos is correct
like I don't know who the writer was say
that I wanna like I want to know who the
writer was of that of that question or
that you know prompt to then be like oh
I know exactly how I'm gonna work this
in like how long were they sitting on
the who is they're like okay we gotta
have who is George Santos when do we
bring this in to Jeopardy do you want to
see the best part about this clip uh-huh
yeah it was posted by Jeopardy shut the
front door so Jeopardy actually pulled
this clip from their show and posted it
on Twitter
that's the best part I mean I other than
the sick [__] burn from Ken Jennings
oh yeah right it but Jeopardy posted
that clip that's I think that's a great
part okay so some other news um before
we leave here
um did you know that a bunch of
Republicans like Trump Margaret Taylor
Greene Ted Cruz Matt Gantz um several of
these other uh pieces of [__] fascist
they were really they were really
cheering on
um oh yeah getting Paxton to win his
impeachment because they don't like when
criminals especially Republican
criminals especially
Republican criminal politicians get held
accountable and as we know uh Kent
Paxton has been impeached over the
weekend as Texas Attorney not only that
he's been suspended so he's not
currently acting as the attorney general
which is probably a good thing wait
sorry before you go into that uh Edward
Anderson says let me talk to my Lane
lady she's a writer producer who
researches questions for game shows so
Edward if you can find out who wrote
this question or who wrote that prompt
um so here is here is a scene from uh
the impeachment this is uh one of the
Republicans defending Ken Paxton but
it's [__] beautiful how they're
defending these crimes now if you're if
you're still standing around wondering
why Donald Trump is going to be the
nominee and how he's going to be the
nominee I I give you the case of Ken
Paxton in Texas but listen listen to
them defend him let's let's listen are
you aware that both Trump and Cruz made
statements about this today
okay they both did and I'll I'll spare
the body some of the statements that
Trump made because I I don't want to
engage in personalities
um but Ted Cruz are you aware that he's
a constitutional attorney
okay so you remember this is the United
States senator of
of of Texas he's a constitution listen
to the answer
I'm not advised
he didn't know that that Ted Cruz
a lawyer because he doesn't sure sorry I
thought you were laughing at his
mustache at first well I'm this guy look
at this I mean like I can't grow a
mustache like that so Props this guy but
also
the idea that listen if you can grow a
mustache like this no no I probably
should I'm not saying I'm not I'm not
dogging on the mustache I'm dying on the
fact that like
if it reminds me of the of uh wasn't
there another wasn't there another
lawyer that Trump had that has that same
curly q [__] Jesus Christ Mighty
librarian I never knew this check out
that flavored saver
oh
oh mustache rides okay so listen here's
the thing when this guy says
Donald Trump and Ted Cruz are supporting
Ken Paxton that should be like okay then
let's get rid of that [__] like
that should be just all the evidence you
need to get rid of Ken Paxton you don't
need any other bribery or [__]
obstruction of justice charges just
Trump and Ted Cruz is supporting him at
the same time because he's a criminal is
enough for me like that for me that's a
bar that I could reach to say Ed
probably not a good idea to have this
person anywhere near government if Ted
Cruz and Donald Trump are in support of
him and the answer to my question is Ty
Cobb
that's the other per that's that's the
Trump attorney with the yes that's right
that's right because I was like this guy
I was like I know I've seen this before
and the other the other like image I had
was if anyone watches succession which
just
had their series finale last night uh
one one of one of the advisors to the
brother
he has that he has a similar type of
like you know like Oh I'm a I'm an
advisor and I'm a constitutional I'm
running the campaign kind of thing he's
got a similar kind of mustache but he's
got I think uh uh chops as well uh
whenever I see people like that and
they're always like oh I'm the
I'm the expert in this field or I know
exactly how to do this you know and
you're like oh you're a [__] idiot
the best part though is that this person
has to be advised that Ted Cruz the
Constitutional lawyer because you
wouldn't know it otherwise you wouldn't
know it otherwise well let's listen to
the conclusion here this this cherry on
top is what made me love this clip yes
and and he is he basically talks about
the swamp once uh once this individual
moved out of their office and he's
showing full support
for the Attorney General he's showing
full support he's a constitutional
attorney who I don't know if you go look
at the Constitution you would see that
there's criminal statutes that you would
probably not want someone and you could
impeach them there's a Texas
Constitution I'm sure he knows there's a
Texas Constitution in that Constitution
yeah you can impeach an attorney general
if that I don't know they're caught
bribing people they're obstructing
justice you can impeach them now uh Kim
Paxton as of right now I don't believe
he's been officially removed he is
suspended from attorney general he does
not hold the power of attorney general
right now because he's been impeached
and yeah temporarily is right
um but it looks like it looks like Ken
Paxton will be removed yeah um as
attorney general and not only that
um it is not surprising that Marjorie
Taylor green Donald Trump Ted Cruz all
these criminal Republicans are
supporting a criminal Republican in Ken
Paxton um and folks again I I know I
keep telling you that no matter what
happens to Trump he's going to be the
nominee but this is your road map here
um of what is going to happen now I will
also say this is the road map to Donald
Trump's downfall and the reason why is
because they're gonna it's gonna rally
support
and and it's going to look like people
are supporting a criminal because they
are and it's not going to work it's not
going to be enough support to fend off
another election loss and a huge loss
for Republicans which I'm excited about
are you excited about I'm super excited
like there's never been a moment when
I've been more excited right well then
never like even I don't know the prime
parade and SF you said it was weird yeah
I mean that was pretty exciting okay but
look I guess if there was a moment
that'd be more exciting I mean here
Ken Paxton is definitely there in terms
of getting you know charged going to
jail and then Donald Trump is definitely
above that in terms of excitement I know
Pride Parade's kind of above that for
sure I mean a lot of fun a lot of fun
okay uh but there is also a part of me
that's like I don't know Donald Trump
going to prison and never being able to
run for president again
let me tell you something him losing is
at the top of my list and I can't wait
for him to destroy Ron DeSantis in the
meantime while he's losing oh yeah just
just like they're stepping on rakes
everywhere oh speaking of rakes I think
we're gonna have the rake merch already
this afternoon I will post it on social
media once it's posted we'll we'll air
it tomorrow when everyone's here and
then we're past the holiday and everyone
will be able to get excited about the
rake merch so be looking for that this
afternoon either on Twitter Facebook
um or Instagram we'll be posting that um
and we'll probably post it on YouTube
here in the community Ted so be looking
for the rape merch as we post that this
afternoon
boy we're running out of time that sucks
right at two hours
that sucks that sucks no I want to go
longer I get some more stuff I'm gonna I
here's the thing I'm gonna go I think
we're gonna go swimming this afternoon
as a memorial day so I'm gonna edit I'm
gonna edit the audio version I'll get it
up on the uh the directories for you
guys to download we'll get the rake
merch done so you guys can have that and
then I'm gonna go um go hit the pool so
hey man man go celebrate get some get
some sun don't burn make sure to wear
sunscreen you know okay I am no you kind
of uh you white people you know pasty
white pasty white don't forget to
subscribe here at the Tony Michaels
podcast on YouTube watch us every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch Twitter follow us at
Tony Michaels pod on Facebook you can
watch at the Tony Michaels follow us on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels also if
you haven't renewed your subscription on
Twitch your Prime subscription go do it
now go do it now several of you have
this morning so thank you very much
everyone re-sub over on Twitch if you
have haven't done already and if you
want to know how to link your Prime
account to your Twitch account just go
to the Tony michaels.com the link is
there to do that to give us the
subscription it's free to follow so over
there follow it's free and it's also
free it's also free to download every
single episode on Apple Spotify and
Google be looking for that this
afternoon as I get that edited before I
go get sunburned at the pool
buoyance whatever the hell weekend did
you have a good weekend yeah man I had a
I went to a pool party uh friends pool
party yesterday saw some people said
hello you know okay did the old thing
and uh yeah you know awesome well it's a
great Memorial Day and I want to thank
and and I appreciate all the people who
have
um been in the service uh whether it's
your relatives you personally anyone
that we've lost because it is important
that they fought for our freedom uh
truly and our real Freedom not the
freedom at the right claims I'm talking
about real Liberty real rights real
freedom and you are an integral part of
that by engaging in your democracy every
single weekday right here on the Tony
Michaels podcast
I hope you have a rest of your safe
holiday weekend today
tomorrow you know where we'll be Saint
Time same place Surf's Up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__]
them
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon